les banques en font-elles suffisamment
pour le climat ça se discute avec vous
Philippe Brassac bonjour bonjour merci
d'être là avec nous directeur général du
Crédit Agricole quand on écoute Laye
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
elle nous dit que pour contenir
l'augmentation et température 1,5 degrés
d'ici la fin du siècle les banques
doivent cesser d'investir dans les
nouveaux projets pétroliers et gaziers
pourquoi ne pas le faire pourquoi le
stopper pourquoi ne pas stopper tout de
suite vos investissements dans tout ce
qui est fossiles comme vous le réclame
les ONG vous l'avez fait avec le charbon
pourquoi ne pas faire pareil pour le
pétrir et le gaz alors je réponds
directement à votre question mais je
pense qu'il faut remettre cette
révolution industrielle dans une cadre
beaucoup plus globale parce qu'il faut à
la fois faire apparaître le verre il
faut sortir du fossile il faut équiper
toute la société donc la seule question
du fossile est une question partielle
par rapport au sujet mais je réponds à
votre question mais c'est une question
parce que nous sommes très interrogés
là-dessus en disant fond pourquoi vous
financez le fossile la réponse est assez
simple l'économie actuelle n'a besoin
mais pourquoi vous financeriez encore
les nouvelles d'exploration il se trouve
que nous avons décidé de ne plus
financer de nouvelles explorations pas
mal de banques en tout cas le groupe
Frédéric cold mais jaune pétrole et gaz
j'ose pointer le point suivant comment
se fait-il que la sphère publique soit
pas plus clair là-dessus pourquoi c'est
à moi bancaire de terme terminé si je
dois financer totalement d'autres sur de
nouvelles explorations en nous ou
ailleurs pourquoi est-ce une question de
conscience du banquier plutôt que notre
cadre directeur public qui dirait voilà
ce qu'il faut faire ne pas faire parce
que il faut faire attention de ne pas
faire s'effondrer l'économie ou bien on
peut prendre le risque de je trouve que
cette question unique sur les banques
doivent s'engager fait apparaître une
sorte de déficit ou de carence de cadre
global donc c'est la faute qui n'ont pas
défini un cadre assez clair il manque un
cadre suffisamment clair je pense que
par exemple ce qui va être sorti dans le
cadre de l'industrie verte est un cadre
positif dans lequel il faut s'inscrire
mais on se rappelle de ce débat qui est
au fond assez venimeux et qui consiste
juste à dire voilà ce qu'il faut plus
faire mais ne plus faire ne suffira pas
il faut clairement dire en 2025 en 2030
comment la société de roi fonctionner
quel sera le mix énergétique et que tous
les acteurs les banques y compris bien
sûr mais que tous les acteurs s'engagent
là-dedans donc pour l'instant nous nous
prenons par défaut cette option qui
consiste à dire ok on va plus financer
les nouvelles explorations mais c'est
quand même curieux que ce ne soit pas
validé par les autorités publiques dans
le cadre d'un schéma d'irrateur qui nous
rassurerait ce qui est intéressant c'est
que et c'est ce que vous nous dites
c'est que vous financez finalement
l'économie telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
bien sûr et donc ça signifie qu'elle est
peut-être pas aussi assez verte et votre
portefeuille de crédit reflète mais
justement l'état de l'économie qui est
encore qu'on le déplore ou pas carboné
mais moi je pense qu'il faut plus
déplorer il faut constater que il faut
décarboner l'économie elle s'est
carbonée toute seule durant le 20e
siècle ça n'a pas été un plan global
c'est l'économie qui est en mode des
décennies c'est devenu carbone
les consommateurs les industriels les
investisseurs bon maintenant il faut
changer cela la révolution du
non-carbonate fera le problème c'est
qu'elle sera beaucoup trop longue donc
il faut l'accélérer l'accélérer c'est
d'abord financer et accélérer l'arrivée
des énergies non carbonées en tout cas
les énergies non renouvelables pardon
les unr en l'occurrence ça se fait et
d'ailleurs on en parle très peu mais la
vraie difficulté aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
n'y a pas assez de gros projets les
grands projets les financements sont
tous financiers des grands projets
qu'ils soient solaires ou éolien entier
ou offshore les banquiers les
investisseurs les essais de managers se
jettent dessus de dire qu'il y a pas
assez de projet on l'explique
ça se comprend très bien je pense au
contraire c'est à dire que cette affaire
est très compliquée on n'a pas fait
l'industrie carbonée en 5 ans elle s'est
fait un siècle donc aujourd'hui on est
besoin au fond de cadre
d'investissement pour toute la société
et accélérer cela c'est très compliqué
dans le diagnostic de industrie verte il
y a cette idée qui nous manque de projet
parce que des projets c'est long et
qu'on a plus en plus le temps d'attendre
les équilibres de business model que
l'offre et la demande s'équilibre il
faut forcer la marche il faut plus
respecter l'obsolescence technologique
parce que ceux qui m'ont investir
maintenant dans cinq ans ce sera
peut-être et bien c'est pas grave il
faut prendre des risques nouveaux et
donc cette accélération de l'arrivée des
énergies renouvelables c'est une
aventure en tant que telle je voudrais
qu'un pointé le fait que la finance de
façon générale notamment la finance
française est totalement mobilisée
là-dessus vous n'entendez d'ailleurs
jamais la question posée est-ce que vous
avez suffisamment financé d'énergie
renouvelable on nous demande juste de
nous retirer ou de tirer le tapis sous
les énergies fossiles en tant que tel
que vous avez fait pour le Crédit
Agricole ce qu'on n'a pas fait
totalement parce que la responsabilité
pour le coup de continuer à financer
financer les nouveaux projets plus les
nouvelles explorations ce qui je le dis
très à plat est une prise de position on
va dire quasiment commercial de
réputationnel parce qu'on est tellement
agressé le dessus qu'on s'est engagé à
ne pas y aller mais je voudrais en toute
responsabilité montrer que c'est quand
même curieux qu'on laisse la sphère
économique libérale nous banquiers on
est censé financer tout ce qui n'est pas
interdit et non pas commencer à décider
ce qui est bien ou mal après il y a un
hitarade des pollueurs qui étaient
établis par carbone 4 finances dans un
sérieux et vous savez j'étais un peu
surpris qui on trouve sur le podium pas
total énergie mais trois banques
françaises BNP Paribas Société Générale
et vous
il est discutable ce classement pour
vous parce que vous ne polluez pas
directement vous ne faites que financer
je me entre guillemets des pollueurs
mais écoutez on prend tout simplement
avec BNP Paribas et dixième banque au
monde voilà
Crédit Agricole c'est 2000 milliards de
bidons de de de d'activités bancaires
donc nous avons énormément de clients
énormément de d'activités et nous sommes
grosso modo le financeur de 25% de
l'économie française toutes l'économie
française celle des énergies
renouvelables aujourd'hui comme celle
d'énergie qui ne le sont pas à distance
et on compte dans notre SCOP de mission
carbone tous les clients que nous
finançons les constructeurs automobiles
qui soient électriques ou pas les
consommateurs qui utilisent au fond le
l'essence par les par par les pétroliers
ou pas c'est toute cette économie qui
est comptabilisée sur nous si nous
faisions l'addition des principales
banques commandes nous ferions 10 fois
la planète mais moi je comptais pas ce
calcul là parce que la méthode est utile
c'est-à-dire que ça nous permet d'avoir
des métriques sur lesquelles on va
s'engager à diminuer
l'intensité des missions carbone de nos
portefeuilles c'est la valeur absolue
n'a pas de sens mais la métrique et le
fait qu'on doit nous engager à réduire à
ça ça a beaucoup de sens et donc
pourquoi pas traiter plus cher aux
entreprises qui sont plus polluantes ou
qui ne sont pas engagés dans une
trajection une trajectoire des missions
carbone suffisamment crédible et
peut-être prêter moins cher aussi pour
les boîtes qui sont plus vertueuses mais
une seule fois votre nouvelle fois je
pense que je pense que on accélèrera pas
si on ne passe autant essayer de punir
ou à dissuader la récompenser aussi les
bons élèves oui mais ça on le fait
souvent par des taux qui sont bonifiés
que ce soit privé ou la sphère publique
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la question
c'est ça lui de l'accélération quand on
s'est engagé les banques françaises
étaient une première au monde à le faire
en disant on va plus financer le charbon
très bien on finance plus charbon et ça
fait pas des énergies renouvelables pour
autant nouvelle fois je pense qu'il faut
bien avoir en tête que il faut faire
migrer toute la société avoir des
énergies renouvelables à l'échelle on y
est pas ces significations mais on n'y
est pas encore il faut accélérer il faut
sortir du fossile mais pas comme comment
dire des voleurs en partant les sans
tomber l'économie tel cadet
l'accompagnant les practice comme disait
les anglovations
dans les énergies fossiles combien
d'euros vous financer dans les énergies
renouvelables est-ce que cette question
a un sens d'ailleurs et est-ce que vous
avez des chiffres alors ce qu'on a comme
chiffres c'est ce qu'on fait sur les
énergies renouvelables parce que on est
loin d'être dans des choses symboliques
le groupe Crédit Agricole est cité BNP
Paribas c'est une signe très grande
banque il se trouve que quand vous
prenez les obligations vertes c'est à
dire les émissions d'obligation qu'on
fait sur le marché pour que les très
grandes entreprises les grandes
entreprises puissent investir vers du
verre sur les trois premières banques au
monde il y a deux Françaises BNP Paribas
et groupe Crédit Agricole on a participé
en 2022 à l'arrangement de 35 milliards
d'euros d'obligations vertes il se
trouve que comme on parle pas du fossile
on nous dit c'est devenu washing c'est
pas du greenwashing nous aidons dans les
énergies renouvelables au fond des
investissements très importants vers
l'équipement des très grandes
entreprises est-ce que vous sentez en
finir là-dessus que vous client en
particulier vous demande de plus en plus
de mettre leur argent justement au
service du climat et de projet vertueux
est-ce que ça reste marginal je pense
qu'il y a une dizaine d'années la
question climatique était encore une
question qualifiée de façon péjorative
d'éco au sens péjoratif du terme
maintenant c'est terminé la société
convaincue très grande majoritaire cette
question est centrale pour nous pour nos
enfants pour les petits enfants et donc
la société est non seulement convaincue
mais elle est anxieuse de cela le
problème c'est qu'on passe à une phase
si on donne pas le projet à une phase
qui est une phase un peu de colère sur
nous-mêmes comment se fait-il qu'il y a
encore du pétrole du gaz qui investit
qui consomment cela donc vous attendez
une vision politique j'attends de driver
vers les solutions mais ça existe la
question c'est pas tellement de changer
le logiciel c'est qu'il faut se donner
comme idée qu'il faut accélérer et
arrêter de passer son temps de savoir au
fond de culpabiliser ou des ménages ou
des procès vous entreprises ou des
banques savoir mais comment se fait-il
que vous êtes encore sur du financement
en gaz ou pétrole alors que la vraie
question c'est comment on transforme et
on substitue ces énergies là par
d'autres types d'énergie et comment on
accélère là-dessus absolument merci pour
cette entrée en général du Crédit
Agricole voilà c'est la fin de pourvu
que ça dure l'émission qui rend les
co-responsables émissions à voir ou
revoir ce public Sénat en replay bien
sûr sur publicsena.fr rendez-vous dans
deux semaines
[Musique]